that Alexa is tricky I read an article
recently it said Alexa actually listens
to everything you say stores it in a
database could use it against you later
I like damn just like a real
woman now I'm all nervous like hey Alexa
what's the weather out there she's like
why don't you ask Siri oh boy yeah it's
got to be hard to be a kid now I feel
bad for kids so much stimulus coming at
kids iPhone internet social media
remember how happy go lucky were kids
not a care in the world maybe run of the
car shotgun that was like the biggest my
life
shotgun yeah I never see kids doing that
anymore the only time a kid yells it out
now is in a classroom oh w